incoming bonus content  hi i'm rachel jacks and i'm anna  gasteyer and we're gonna take the best  this is a give kitty this is a gimme  therapist therapist can i can we write  two  can we write two okay  at least we know both  okay  okay ready set  go  oh we got it oh my god oh my god i love  that  best friends and look we have to flip  them best friends best friends  okay ready set go  oh that was my other thought i bet i did  because then we said okay no but you're  right  that is because violin was one thing  that i did think of first and then this  is like well you wouldn't know she's a  very good cook you wouldn't know that's  actually a better answer because i do  this sometimes that's that's exactly  what i thought  anyway in my mind we're still three for  three yeah but okay that's what best  friends do okay  this is a terrible answer  okay  [Laughter]  this pretty much sums her up in two  words  [Laughter]  and that was a little bit extra for you  [Music]  you